we're traveling to kayla from movie
where we've been for the past two months
[Music]
it's still kind of dangerous to go back
before you really wanted to go back home
to check on our apartment and the
parents so we're going back
[Music]
roads to kiev have been perfect like
this specific highway we're on in this
cave chop which goes all the way to
western ukraine
traveling to cave is about seven to
eight hours the biggest issue is getting
gas so we're at a gas station right now
not a lot of them have any kind of gas
a lot of them have limitations and how
much you can get into one car so we have
to visit quite a few of them on the way
all the signs and all the guidance and
directions across the world has been
removed once the wash started we have
gotten information
and guidance from our government in many
ways and one of the ways has been for
the people to remove the signs and
basically any names of cities and
villages that are on the road as you
travel so if and when russian occupants
make it to this specific region it's
very hard for them to orient even for us
when we're traveling back home we really
have to go with the map because there
there are no uh pointers on where to
travel and you really have to know the
road to get back home
so we're in cave region right now
probably around 10 to 15 miles from cave
there's a lot of destruction here a lot
of residential homes a lot of
infrastructure
the bridge over the road this has been a
way to cross the highway has been
entirely removed by our governmental
officials in the army so the occupants
job would be harder to get to places and
to
settle here for a longer period of time
we saw multiple bridges like this
even though the cities around cave and
the region and the villages have taken a
lot of
heavy fighting and destruction
everything has been removed apart from
just a few pieces of like tanks or
machinery just for people to see the
destroyed russian vehicles
[Music]
[Music]
you